I'm on the beach in Rio de Janeiro in
Brazil part of my trip to Brazil to
conferences and so on but while I was
here I wanted to tell you about an
interesting piece of chemistry that I've
just read about because it concerns sand
and I've never seen so much sand as
there is here sand is made up of silica
sio2 like co2 but with silicon instead
of carbon and because silicon is further
down the periodic table than carbon it
bonds differently so instead of having
sio2 molecules you have a network of SiO
4 units silicon with four oxygens and
each oxygen is joined to more silicon
atoms so you get a very hard solid
material and sand is made up of silica
silica is white so the yellow color
comes from a tiny bit of iron that's in
the sand now the interesting paper that
I read about was about xenon and think
about it
what xenon got to do with the beach well
according to this paper which was
published in the Journal of the American
Chemical Society a very famous chemistry
journal there isn't as much xenon in the
atmosphere as people would expect well
people can look at the amount of neon
argon Krypton and predict how much xenon
they would expect and there's much less
than they would actually expect on the
basis of the other noble gases and so
what this paper was suggesting is that
xenon dioxide could be incorporated into
silicon what they mean by that is that
just occasionally in the silica
structure instead of having SiO 4 unit
you would have an x EO 4 unit now this
is slightly complicated because SiO 4 is
tetrahedral whereas X Co 4 is planar
it's flat so it would disrupt the
structure but if there was only a little
bit of xenon in among the silicon it
probably would not affect the structure
too much xenon of course is very inert
so you may ask how can it react with
oxygen and the answer is that it is
pretty a nerves and if you have solid
xenon trioxide if you touch it with a
feather it explodes because the bonds
are so weak but you have to imagine it
trapped inside the solid just one
molecule inside a vast amount of sio2
silica and it just can't decompose
because it's stuck in the solid rather
like a cherry in the middle of a cake
and so it's believed that this would be
stable and you've just got to look round
here so just imagine with all the sands
if one silicon atom out of a billion
hundred billion thousand billion was
replaced by xenon it wouldn't affect the
structure of the silica but you'd still
have an awful lot of xenon trapped in
all the sand in the world and I have no
idea whether this is right or not but it
is quite an interesting thought that
when you're sitting here on the beach
you may be sitting on the small amount
of a xenon compound
you